So a major interest that we have in our
lab is understanding immunological memory
to the infections that we have gotten as
children or even as adults or the
vaccines that we get as children. Immunological memory is the ability of the
immune system to respond much faster
upon re-exposure to the same pathogen,
and that's the basis of vaccination.
So if you get as a child, you get a
polio vaccine or a measles or mumps
vaccination, then protected from
that disease for many, many years,
sometimes for life, and the reason for
that is because you've got memory -- you've
got T-cells and B-cells that recognize
that pathogen and will protect you
immediately upon re-exposure to that pathogen.
So our lab has been interested
understanding how long-term immune
memory or immunologic memory is
maintained after either infection or vaccination.
So what we'll cover in my
presentation today are four things.
First, I'll talk to you about logical
memory. Then I'll talk to you about
in particular the properties
of memory T-cells --
what makes memory T-cells do what they
do, which is protect us from infections
or in rapid response, something
about the properties of memory T-cells.
And then I will switch to what for us
was a very exciting line of research,
which is what happens if there's a
chronic infection so start with them
logical memory, then talk about
functional memory T-cells you get after
an acute infection or vaccination.
And then tell you about what happens if
there is a chronic, persistent antigenic
stimulus, as you have during chronic
infections or in the conditions of a
cancer, with the constant stimulation of a
humor antigen. And then I'll tell you
about a inhibitory receptor that
actually results in dysfunction of these
T-cells during a chronic infection or in
a tumor setting , so it's like a brake
that comes on and keeps them from being functional.
And then I'll talk to you
about how you can restore function in
these cells by releasing that
that brake. And then I'll end by the
clinical implications in treatment of
cancer of using the PD one directed immunotherapy.